yesterday on the show I pointed out that
today ordinary common run-of-the-mill
people have a more sophisticated
understanding of politics than the
professional pundit and politician class
and I don't even mean that the people
just happen to agree with us more
I mean very technically they actually
know more things about the events that
shape our politics and once again
nostradamus's prophecy was proven
correct later that very day when
ordinary conservative voters absolutely
wrecked msnbc's ridiculous narrative
over January 6th
Doug mastriano was at the Insurrection
and he was photographed breaching one of
the restricted areas
is that okay which area because I saw a
video where Capital officers was taking
away barriers and unlocking doors
I mean I they opened the gate so it
shouldn't be disqualifying for an
elected official if they participated in
January 6. he didn't strike anybody he
didn't hurt anybody and the only one
that died was a protester there not a
capital police unarmed female veteran
that's the only one that died the only
one who died a police officer did die no
so what do you make though overall of
January 6th I mean it was watching that
footage it was pretty disturbing I mean
there were people throwing excrement at
the walls and it was our you know the
capital it almost a lot like antifa's
actually
except on a much smaller scale it looked
the same as the black lives matter right
that's what I saw the similarities
One Burns Kenosha but so it's okay just
because just because one side that you
disagree with
notice how she keeps moving the goal
posts she says well the Insurrection
well it wasn't really an Insurrection
well you know but all the violence yeah
actually the only really the only
violence the only at least the only
killing was against the Trump supporters
well you know but it was a complete uh
Mass Invasion and attack of the capital
actually some cops kind of moved the
barricades and opened up the doors for
them well but don't you don't you don't
you pull after Pole shows
people get it they get it a lot better
than the chattering class they're in
possession of much more information and
motivation than the largely ignorant
almost entirely liberal
pun-datocracy now the powers that be
have a choice
do they let the people have the
government they want or do they clamp
down even further to get their own way
I'm Michael knowlesist the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from Vinnie Durham
who says I wish I would have known
Michael was in England I'm British and
would have loved to have met him feels
like a once in a lifetime opportunity
missed no I assure you my friend it is
not a once in a lifetime opportunity
they will make me the Prime Minister
eventually it's only a matter of time
they almost did this time instead they
picked an Indian guy who looks a lot
like me so it was pretty it was kind of
looked like my Indian cousin you know
and I assume I'll be back very very soon
to take over the government and
reinstitute real real conservatism back
in in the motherland so don't worry just
stay tuned because we got to protect our
countries and our communities and our
homes and when you want to protect your
home you got to check out ring it is a
wonderful time of year fall has so many
wonderful things to enjoy and I'm not
just talking about pumpkin spice lattes
the kids are back in school the chaos of
Summer travel has come to an end and you
can really get back into the swing of
things now for many of us fall also can
mean a lot of busy stuff you know we're
work school sports clubs the list goes
on and on you may find yourself away
from home more often than not which is
why I've decided to team up with ring
with ring security products you can rest
assured that your home and family will
be safe when you're not there the ring
doorbell notifies you when guests or
packages arrive working parents you can
even watch from the office to make sure
your kids get off the school bus safely
Rings indoor cameras are a great way to
keep an eye on kids and pets when you're
not there ring alarm will alert you if
any motion is detected while the house
is empty plus if you add smart lighting
around your home you can turn lights on
or off while you're away or link your
lights to select ring video doorbells
and security cameras so they shine when
motion is detected I love ring it makes
me feel much much safer especially when
I'm on the road head on over to ring.com
to find out how you can live stress-free
this season with a ring product that is
right for you that is ring.com
absolutely wonderful day yesterday
for watching conservatives destroy the
libs on television I thought that focus
group talking to that MSNBC reporter and
correcting her facts repeatedly it was
such a breath of fresh air it was so
delightful and then it was followed up
by my pal Senator Ted Cruz going on The
View and absolutely reading those poor
cackling hens the riot act try to say
the election was fair and square and
legitimate you know who y'all don't do
that to you don't do it to Hillary
Clinton who stood up and said Trump
stole the election
who said that the election was stolen
they sat here and said it was
illegitimate and you guys were fine with
it okay so it's illegitimately
Republicans
no you know here's the thing we may not
like when Republicans win but we don't
go and we don't storm we don't try to
change but
hold on
did I miss an entire year of antifa
riots where cities across us
of doing something we didn't do you said
Hillary Clinton didn't say whatever she
didn't say I'm saying to you listen and
she said we stand here and you were fine
with her saying it was illegitimate
she called Donald Trump the next morning
and she conceded the election Ted okay
sunny she sat there while while Donald
Trump is an illegitimate president
Hillary Clinton says the election is
stolen from you Hillary Clinton in 2002
George W Bush was selected Not Elected
Joe Biden Al Gore was was elected
president so Joe Biden yeah
I love it at the end the only thing that
they've got the only thing that they can
possibly say is hey hey
keep your voice down
that's at Anna Navarro who's one of the
two fake Republicans on The View there's
the the three Libs and then the two fake
Republicans Anna Navarro and that chick
who worked in the Trump Administration
and there but they're both effectively
Democrats and all they ever do is
support Democrats and so after they
tried so hard they said Democrats never
they they never storm any buildings they
never Riot or anything and say like well
what about BLM and antifa for eight
freaking months well the Democrats never
questioned the elections um actually
I've got the receipts right here they
constantly question elections with far
less Reason by the way than the
Republicans had in 2020. well the well
the hey Ted keep your voice down
yeah right because he just completely
destroyed your ridiculous narrative with
facts and logic what what he's saying is
there's just two sets of rules here and
so Senator Cruz goes on TV he says
absolutely not uh we're we're uh we're
gonna push back now we're going to not
accept your ridiculous narratives and
and have to clutch our pearls and say
well you know you're right about the
January sixth well you're right about
Donald Trump and the Terry says no you
guys do way worse stuff than we do way
way worse stuff you uh frankly are lying
about the events that the Donald Donald
Trump's denying the election or January
6th or whatever you're lying about it
anyway we're just not going to take it
anymore we're not going to play that
game I think at this point if the
election were fair and square it would
be an absolute Landslide they have to
cheat
they have to cheat it's the only way
that they're going to win and you're
already seeing this happen so right now
I mentioned yesterday on the show John
fetterman who's that that Democrat
Senate candidate in Pennsylvania
fetterman finally agreed to a debate
with the Republican candidate Dr Oz now
of course fetterman pushed the debate as
long as he possibly could as late into
the game as possible because voting's
already been going on in Pennsylvania
since September so he's hoping okay well
I'm obviously going to look terrible at
the debate but if I can encourage enough
people to vote before the debate even
happens then it's not going to matter
quite as much and now John fetterman's
campaign is insisting that he'd be
allowed to use an earpiece during the
debate and so why will he use the
earpiece they're saying it's because he
had a stroke
and his health is obviously terrible and
he's certainly not fit to be a U.S
senator he's not morally fit or
intellectually fit but now he's not even
fit as a matter of his own health and so
he needs the earpiece to help with his
quote lingering auditory processing
issues
so they say we are prepared for Dr Oz's
allies and right-wing media to circulate
malicious viral videos after the debate
to try to paint John in a negative light
because of awkward pauses missing some
words and mushing other words together
John has had a remarkable recovery but
the ongoing auditory processing
challenges are real the campaign
insisted on closed captioning technology
because it's necessary so notice what
they're saying malicious awful terrible
viral videos of
John fetterman in his own words
malicious awful terrible dishonest fake
News videos just of this man speaking
isn't it it's so malicious to present to
the Democrats
saying what they will say and doing what
they will do but furthermore
do you remember
in years past
when there were these kind of crazy
conspiracy theories that certain weaker
candidates would have an earbud in
during the debate
to get
information you get direction during the
debate and and you say I don't know in
that debate Joe Biden that guy is so
slow but I bet he had an earbud in and
so that's a crazy wild conspiracy theory
now they're just doing it openly now
they're just doing it brazenly they are
actually wearing earbuds and they're
saying yeah we're gonna wear earbuds
during the debate why oh because our
candidate doesn't understand anything
so we need to feed him information
during the debate
yeah yeah
yeah what do you and what are you going
to do about it nothing nothing
they're not even hiding it it's the
powers that be are getting so much more
Brazen about this there was a great this
was probably the greatest tweet of the
entire month it just popped up it's from
Max boot you know he's that fake
Republican who writes for the Washington
Post he said
if current trends hold up Republicans
are likely to take over at least the
house and quite possibly the Senate too
along with many State offices this is
how democracies die both at home and
abroad
if current trends hold up the people are
going to elect Republicans
this is how democracies die both at home
and abroad
not sure what that word democracy means
and well what it shows you is that the
Democrats
and the entire liberal establishment
which includes the fake Republicans as
well like you know on The View they have
two fake Republicans Anna Navarro and
that chick from the Trump Administration
but they're they're effectively
Democrats that all they ever do is
support Democrats and Max boot the same
thing he just supports Democrats and and
what they're telling you is that their
their understanding of democracy has
nothing to do with the actual meaning of
the word democracy
their understanding of the word
democracy is the liberal status quo and
so when the people challenge the liberal
status quo when the people speak out
against the lies that were being told
when the focus group from Pennsylvania
goes on MSNBC and says you're actually
lying about this and lying about that
and you're misrepresenting this and we
actually have the facts then we're told
well that's a threat to demand when the
people want their voices heard
that is of course a threat to democracy
now when we want to protect our assets
from this crazy tempestuous climate
we need to check out Birch gold
right now text Knowles to
989898 the labor Department's Consumer
Price Index which catalogs the cost of
goods Services food and rent Rose 0.4
percent over the month of August double
what many economists had anticipated
perhaps worse core inflation which
excludes food and gas prices saw the
highest increase last month that it has
seen since August 1982. what is the
current Administration doing to quell
The Surge of inflation
spending more of your taxpayer dollars
of course don't bury your head in the
sand while your savings deplete
diversify into gold with Birch gold
today text Knowles kwles to 989898 and
Birch gold will send you a free info kit
on protecting your savings with gold in
a tax sheltered account the experts over
at Birch gold have almost 20 years of
experience in converting IRAs and 401ks
into precious metals IRAs gold has
always been your best hedge against
inflation a diversified savings can
protect you from the downturns in the
market if you have a 401k or IRA that's
underperforming just text Knowles kwels
to 989898 and you can convert that into
an IRA in Precious Metals right now
Birch gold group has an A plus rating
from the Better Business Bureau text
Knowles to 98 9898 and Birch gold will
send you a free info kit on diversifying
into gold tax-free take the necessary
steps to hedge against inflation today
protect your hard-earned money get your
free info kit by texting nulls to
989-898 now
speaking of the brazenness of our ruling
Elite
you've got a situation now where
the the people who in any way question
the regime
will face horrible horrible consequences
they could be they'll be investigated
they could be imprisoned thrown in
solitary confinement you know like the
like the grannies who's who stormed the
capital rotunda on January 6th they they
could be uh ordered by a court to pay a
billion dollars or now possibly even
trillions of dollars in the case of Alex
Jones we'll get to that a little bit
later or or sometime this week you you
see that anytime any conservative does
anything that can even be somehow
Twisted as being wrong they'll have the
book thrown at them meanwhile the people
who lie and cheat and steal and deceive
us
with far greater power and efficacy
those people get off scot-free and the
greatest example of this of course is
that fauji algae that some of us
were very skeptical of from the very
beginning and we had episodes of this
show taken off the internet because we
raised doubts about the efficacy of That
vaccine to prevent you from Catching
covid about the efficacy of That vaccine
to stop you from transmitting covid and
now they're not only are they admitting
that are the establishment Powers
admitting that we were right the whole
time but they're now denying that they
ever contradicted us great example of
this was just trending on Twitter
foreign
claims about Pfizer's covid-19 vaccine
trial and impact on transmission are
misleading
fact Checkers report according to the
Associated Press Pfizer never claimed
the clinical trial of their covid-19
vaccine evaluated its effect on
transmission
Reuters also reports that in clinical
trials vaccines were found to give
recipients a high level of protection
against severe disease but effect on
transmission due to trial sizes could
not be immediately determined so we
never said what are you talking about
we're not talking about if you can
transmit the virus or necessarily as a
part of that whether you can contract
the virus no no no we just always said
we advisor always said that the vaccine
will simply prevent you from from coming
down with severe illness or
hospitalization or death right that's
what they said
because I've got a tweet here from
Albert borla who is the CEO and chairman
of Pfizer who says excited to share that
updated analysis from our phase three
study with bioentec shows also showed
that our covid-19 vaccine was 100
effective in preventing covid-19 cases
in South Africa and then just to add a
little cherry on top he says 100 percent
so they're just they're just lying the
Associated Press is lying Twitter is
lying Pfizer is lying and they're lying
in a way
to not only say that we were right in
the first place
but to say in a way to say that we
weren't right because there was never
anything that we were contradicting
because they never made the claim that
we disputed in the first place what are
you talking about
and it's amazing because there were
people there were people on the right
so-called conservatives who at the time
said oh no the vaccines are great
they're so terrific everyone should take
the vaccines maybe we should even
mandate the vaccines they're just so
wonderful and and I thought what are you
basing that on they said well you know
all the studies and all the studies and
all the the promises of the advisor CEO
and Joe Biden and Rachelle valensky and
Dr fagi I thought right but those people
are all liars
they're all liars they're all extremely
corrupt there are huge financial and
political incentives for them to deceive
us they have a track record of deceiving
us and we have very little leverage or
power in this thing at all so why on
Earth would you give them the benefit of
the doubt why on Earth do you think they
have any credibility at all and we were
called crazy wild conspiracy theorists
and now
Pfizer Pfizer itself is trying to
pretend that it had the same opinion we
did the whole time so what else are we
right about remember at the time in the
early days of That vaccine
I I mean I'll just think about my own
wife my wife was pregnant when these
vaccines came out and our families were
really trying very hard to pressure us
to take the fauci algae and my wife was
very
hard line about this and she said I'm
pregnant I'm not taking some
experimental drug certainly not while
I'm pregnant are you insane
and then you hear anecdotal cases about
the about people having problems in
their pregnancies after they took the
vaccine and
you could say well it's just coincidence
well okay there but there are a whole
lot of coincidences that are going on
and you'll remember at the time people
said forget about even pregnancies there
is no way that the vaccine in any way
can affect a woman's menstrual cycle
period not at all it has nothing to do
with that and then what did they admit
six months or a year later
okay well yes it actually does affect
women's menstrual cycles but it's not a
big deal don't worry it's usually only
temporary okay well sometimes it's not
just not just a short period of time but
it'll go anyway never mind it's not a
big deal move on move move on nothing to
see here
these people have no credibility then
you see a video like this has been going
viral on Tick Tock it's Katy Perry
is Katy Perry on stage wearing some
silly costume with her face kind of
glitching out it's actually half of her
face
she's there on stage
and her her eye is super droopy and then
she lifts her her hand up to try to open
her eyelid
but it just dips down again and then
she's got a it's it's horrifying I mean
it's like a
it's out of a cartoon or something like
that and
when you look at that video what does
this have to do with covet or the
vaccines I don't know possibly nothing
but
Katy Perry there looks a lot like Justin
Bieber did uh in in June of this year
Justin Bieber
who said he was suffering from Ramsay
Hunt Syndrome which is similar to Bell's
palsy and his face was partially
paralyzed and you could see that one
side of his face was not cooperating
with the other side of his face
now
he he didn't say at the time that this
was caused by the covet vaccine but
there was a study that was published
last September that highlighted a
connection between Ramsay Hunt syndrome
and the MRNA coronavirus vaccines now
Katy Perry is demonstrating the exact
same behavior I mean there's so many
stories we could be here all day talking
about these stories
and what the libs want you to believe is
if you if you point this out if you
notice this you're a wild crazy
conspiracy theorist you're you're not a
smart sophisticated person you're a wild
crazy ordinary run-of-the-mill probably
local you know overall wearing redneck
hick dummy except for this issue
those overall wearing redneck hicks
don't have any of that big smart
prestigious learning those people
time and time again demonstrate a much
more sophisticated understanding of
politics of just of just the bare facts
of what's going on than all the Geniuses
who have made themselves are are ruling
Elites
those unwashed masses have a much better
record on the major political issues of
our day forget just covid on all of the
big issues on immigration on the economy
on energy on foreign policy they've got
a much better record
than the fauces and the bidens and the
wolenskies and all the all the geniuses
well supposed Geniuses who couldn't
govern their way out of a paper bag
speaking of bizarre performances this is
my absolute favorite story of the week
and it's not getting a ton of play
because it relates to something that
happened like 50 years ago but
it's the story of Sachin littlefeather
you you may or may not remember Sachin
Little Feather when Marlon Brando won
the Oscar for The Godfather he didn't
show up he sent supposedly a Native
American to protest the the uh Academy
of Motion Picture Arts and Sciences this
was a Native American named Sachin
littlefeather
Marlon Brando and The Godfather
accepting the award for Marlon Brando
and The Godfather this little feather
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
s
hello my name is sasheen Little Feather
I'm Apache and I'm president of the
national Native American affirmative
image committee I'm representing Marlon
Brando this evening and he has asked me
to tell you in a very long speech which
I cannot share with you presently
because of time but I will be glad to
share with the Press afterwards that he
very regretfully cannot accept this very
generous award
and the reasons for this being are the
treatment of American Indians today by
the film industry
excuse me
this was one of the most famous moments
in the history of the Oscars apparently
John Wayne had to be restrained from
going up and just like throwing this
woman off the stage but it's a very very
famous moment one really kind of the
beginning of the politicizing of the
Oscars and making it all about this
partisan nonsense well anyway
it was 40 50 years later now it turns
out that that Apache lady Sachin
littlefeather
does not have one drop of Apache blood
in her she and you could you look at her
you say she doesn't really look at
patchy to me it was completely fake she
was the Rachel dollazole of the Oscars
Sachin Little Feather her her biological
sisters Rosalind Cruz and Trudy Orlandi
uh say that little feather is not Native
American at all she says it's a lie my
father was who he was his family came
from Mexico and my dad was born in
Oxnard they're just not Native American
at all and so the reason I bring this up
is
to to
point out how long this kind of crazy
identity politics game has been going on
it's been going on a very very long time
and the kind of delusions of this and
the impulse for people to create their
own
identities
that are frequently divorced totally
divorced from reality and to claim a
kind of victimhood and and the idea that
victimhood carries currency this is not
just some new thing that the snowflakes
invented 10 years ago this this is a an
enduring feature of American politics
that goes back at least 60 years and I
think goes back much further than that
uh also
it it should give conservatives a little
bit of Hope
to think about In This Moment Sachin
littlefeather had
had become this symbol of progress civil
rights
Liberation breaking through the terrible
oppressive treatment of the Native
Americans and all this and then
now overnight
for the people who still think about
that moment at all its meaning has been
completely inverted now it's ugly it's
it's humiliating it's
preposterous is wrong it's bad and it
reminds me of a line from Cardinal
Manning who I quote on this show a fair
bit Manning is the one who said that all
politics ultimately is theological is
another great quote he says there is a
day to come which will reverse The
Confident judgments of men in that day
the first shall be last and the last
first the wise in this world will be
fools and the fools in this world wise
the Mad in this world will be The Heirs
of a better
and this should give conservatives a lot
of confidence there is a day to come
which will reverse The Confident
judgments of men and it doesn't
necessarily feel like that at the moment
we feel like we are so put down the libs
have all of the power they just lie and
lie in line there's very little that we
can do about it
but they I don't think that they will be
able to hold on to that power forever I
don't think the libs are omnipotent okay
and I think they are they are one of the
reasons they are clamping down so much
right now is they feel their power
slipping away they feel their grip
weakening right now on the American
political system I think that's why
they're becoming so much more hysterical
I mean if you were to
hear the story about January 6th
a year ago or a year and a half ago
even a great many conservatives would
believe that
the uh the Trump supporters were armed
they brought guns into the capital they
were about to rape AOC they killed
police officers they were just
exclusively storming the doors tearing
things down they probably set the damn
place on fire and the facts were not
in accordance with that narrative in
fact none of that was true obviously
there was bad stuff that went on people
broke windows and there was there was
plenty of bad stuff that went on but
AOC wasn't even in the building
she was in a different building nearby
but you know come on uh the only people
who were killed on that day at all were
Trump supporters and the only person who
was killed in political violence was
Ashley Babbitt who was killed by a
trigger happy cop the Trump supporters
were not armed they weren't busting in
there with AK-47s and AR-15s and
crucially the Trump supporters were
permitted into the capital in a great
many cases cops moved to the barricades
cops opened the doors in a great many
cases
and just just that totally transforms
your understanding of that day of what
really went on
and it happens very often this happens
just as a matter of history and
historiography our our perception and
our conception of these kinds of events
and of historical figures and historical
movements and and the way that we view
human human nature in the world it can
change very very quickly and I think
that we are on the cusp right now of the
the liberal established view of the
world just collapsing and the people are
clearly clearly waking up about this you
can see speaking of deceptive
appearances you can see the logical
conclusion of the libs just
in insistence on politics is a matter of
just pure tyranny of will divorced from
logic or reason or facts or reality you
can see this in the trial of Daryl
Brooks Daryl Brooks is the Wisconsin guy
who killed six people by driving his SUV
through the Christmas parade
he's a radical BLM supporter and usually
on The Daily wire
we have a policy where we don't name
Mass Killers because we don't want to
encourage other people to do it in this
case though we sort of have to name him
because it's it's essential to the story
of how he is now trying to defend
himself and Daryl Brooks is now trying
to defend himself by saying Daryl Brooks
yeah I don't
sorry that's not who I am anymore
would you can recall
do I remember if I can recall
do you remember the disturbance you
recall
yes I do
would you state what that is what what
that was rather
uh I heard a horn beeping and then a
Ford Escape came through the
um Parade route
and you drove past me and wouldn't stop
and you continued driving into the
parade route
who is you uh Daryl Brooks the defendant
seated at the table
let the record reflect that I do not
identify by their name nor do I know
anybody by that name
objection is noted
so the reason that the killer Daryl
Brooks is questioning the the witness is
because Brooks has decided to be his own
lawyer because he probably is a fairly
crazy person uh and and now his defenses
I don't know anyone by the name of Daryl
Brooks
Daryl no sorry doesn't ring a bell and
sure that seems crazy
why is this crazy why is why is it any
more crazy for Daryl Brooks to say I am
no longer Daryl Brooks than it is for
Richard Levine to say uh now I'm Rachel
Levine I don't know anyone by the name
of Richard Levine no I the assistant
Health secretary I'm Rachel
uh no Bruce Jenner I don't know anybody
by the name of Bruce Jenner I'm Caitlyn
Jenner
why
why is it crazy why it's the same thing
it's exactly the same thing and there
are even a great many conservatives who
will say well you know you can legally
change your name and so I'm perfectly
willing to call Richard Levine Rachel or
whatever
okay so then we shouldn't we should call
Daryl Brooks whatever name he wants to
be called now the order the the killer
formerly known as Daryl Brooks
now what's crazy about him saying I'm no
longer Daryl Brooks is he is insinuating
I think by by saying that that he does
not bear any responsibility for what
Daryl Brooks did namely kill a bunch of
people in a Wisconsin Christmas parade
but
even even if Daryl Brooks no longer were
Daryl Brooks even if he identified as
Rachel Levine or whatever
he uh he he cannot thereby Escape his
responsibility and his obligations and I
think by the way this relates to the
whole transgender question yes you can
conceive of yourself
in any number of ways
I mean this is the this is where I I
kind of think the conservatives go the
wrong direction when they say there's no
such thing as gender expression there's
only there's only sex you know
chromosomes and that sort of thing and
genitals there's no such thing as gender
expression of course there's gender
expression of course men can be
effeminate and women can be Butch of
course
you can have any kind of conception of
yourself that you want
but that doesn't
that doesn't excuse you from your duties
and obligations
and so on the transgender question
men have a responsibility to act like
men I think that's really what it comes
down to I think that's really how we're
going to win the gender question
it's not by denying that people can have
kind of eccentric sexual identities or
sexual desires of course people can it's
a Fallen World you know a ton of people
have weird sexual abuse of themselves
but that that's not an excuse to escape
your responsibilities you you are who
you are
Daryl Brooks did what he did and he's
got to be held responsible for that
Richard Levine is a man and he has a
responsibility to dress like a man and
use a man's name and use the men's
bathroom and not the women's bathroom
and yes that will that will limit his
Indulgence of his fantasies
right we have a response we don't have a
right to just live in Fantasyland
anymore and that you're going to see
this more and more in the coming years
people are sick of Fantasyland because
when when we live in Fantasyland in
politics then there's then we just can't
even communicate with one another we
can't even have a society when we can't
even agree on a basic set of facts or
the meaning of words then there is no
such thing as society and so this is
where you're seeing exasperation from
people like these those Pennsylvania
voters to the MSNBC host or Ted Cruz to
the hosts of The View
he says no no
you're you're you're urinating on my leg
and telling me that it's raining lady I
got the facts I got the receipts okay we
got video we got audio we got everything
say no that's not I don't identify with
Hillary Clinton saying that no that's
not how I identify Stacy Abrams as
denying an election okay
all right fair enough
speaking of identity and Indian women
uh Joe Biden just just paid a very high
compliment to uh Kamala Harris this is
maybe the highest compliment that Kamala
Harris could possibly deserve take a
listen
and you're elected the highest ranking
black Indian with Indian background
woman in American history to be vice
president
the highest ranking
black
Indian
woman with
black I in American you can tell even
Joe Biden is clearly tired of identity
politics
I think he's tired of most things but
he's obviously tired of identity
politics he can't even get through it
seriously and we and this is what the
Democrats always rely on we got to elect
Obama why because he's black
yeah but we don't know anything about
him yeah that's fine he's black yeah he
seems kind of radical right yeah but
he's black
yeah but he's really young and he hasn't
accomplished really anything in his life
and he's got no track record whatsoever
and he's got really some disconcerting
kind of Connections in his past and yeah
yeah but maybe you didn't hear me he's
black and it's so important that we have
a black guy in office for some reason I
don't know why but for some reason
and by the way Barack Obama is Pericles
compared to Kamala Harris I mean Kamala
Harris is one of the least impressive
human beings I've ever seen forget about
at least impressive politicians I
she is one truly one of the least
impressive people I have ever met and
and I know some real derelicts okay I
know some real
real degenerates and come but what does
Kamala Harris done what has she ever
accomplished she's held some political
positions
she
she basically she was picked as vice
president because she's a black woman by
saying it again there
he said it at the time he said I'm going
to pick a black woman
he had three choices Susan Rice who was
the Obama fall man on Benghazi couldn't
be her uh Karen Carol bass Karen bass
who's a actual communist was not that
was not going to work and Kamala Harris
so commonly got it by default I think
she was the first person out in the
Democrat primary yeah but she's a black
Indian
okay all right
great
do you think anyone actually cares about
this do look at public opinion polling
on Kamala Harris
no one likes her no one supports her
but it's it's such a threat to democracy
you see
that now the the majority of the
American people hate the Democrats
policies they hate the Democrat
politicians they hate the direction that
the Democrats are taking the country in
and they fully intend on voting the
Democrats out in two weeks that's a
threat to democracy
right doesn't that make sense
now in other parts of the world
you are seeing the political system
react to the will of the people and
start to take the desires of the people
into account you're seeing this right
now in Mary old England and it did this
announcement come out because I was just
there I don't know maybe I'm not saying
I did cause the UK government to fall
maybe I caused the National Health
Service to abandon the gender affirming
quote-unquote model of care regardless
of the responsibility
this is really great news
the NHS has proposed new guidelines
advocating for a more cautious approach
to treating sexual confusion in minors
after conducting a systemic review of
evidence England's NHS is proposing
these new guidelines they recognize the
children and adolescents identifying as
trans might be experiencing a transient
phase which is really really good and
that doctors should not encourage them
to change their names and pronouns as
social transition is not a neutral act
and that could have significant effects
in terms of psychological functions this
is good this is obviously the right
thing in the vast majority of people
agree with this there was that poll I
just read it on the show yesterday 80
percent of of Americans at least think
that we shouldn't trans the kids and I
I'm certain the numbers are similar in
the United Kingdom and throughout the
entire world of course this is the case
so why is it that the UK is reacting and
actually
get seeding some ground here but in
America you've got Joe Biden absolutely
doubling down you know it feels like a
good time to read another email that the
daily wire was cc'd on in an ongoing ad
segment called breakup letters these are
real messages from former Harry's Razors
customers who cancel their subscriptions
and switched to Jeremy's today's letter
is from a man writing to Harry's quote
I've been a subscriber since 2015 but
I'm canceling because I'm one of the
knuckle dragging Savages that believes
in traditional morality I stuck with you
all after the Gillette razor snafu but
I'm leaving because of your treatment of
daily wire delete my account well said
when it comes to all these woke virtue
signaling companies delete my account is
the new lose my number and frankly the
only acceptable response to a partner
who hates you so if you're a man who
also Believes In traditional masculine
values such as you know um
not wearing a dress or ritualistically
declaring that boys can be girls and
girls can be boys it's time it's a long
past time you ditch your woke razor and
pick up a Jeremy's razor go to
jeremy'srazors.com get 40 off your
Founders shave kit today that's
jeremy'sraisers.com stop giving your
money to woke corporations give it to
Jeremy instead and keep the breakup
emails coming by copying us at reviews
at jeremy'sraisers.com
why is it that the United Kingdom seems
to be more responsive to its voters at
least at least with regard to the
transgender issue then the United States
is I thought the U.S was supposed to be
the most thriving functioning responsive
free and Equitable democracy in the
history of the world
if it ever was that it certainly
wouldn't seem to be that anymore
I I certainly do not think today that
America is the most democratic Nation on
Earth far from it I think there are many
countries that are far more democratic
than the US's and here's the example of
this well one the president of the
United States and half the country says
that if the other half of the country
ever wins power that it's completely
illegitimate and fascistic and we need
to do everything we can to stop it
we need they're they are not legitimate
players in our political process their
very existence poses a threat to
democracy so that would be one big
problem
but but there's there's another issue
which is
the American government right now
does not
seem to have to be responsive to the
people
and and for decades this has been the
case
how is it that the majority of the
American people want to drastically
reduce immigration and yet we only ever
get more and more and more immigration
to the point that we're having three
million immigrants in the last year come
into the country two million of whom are
illegal
how is that the case you've seen a big
push against
uh Imperial Wars abroad
among the American people I suspect the
vast majority of Americans oppose the
kind of Imperial Wars that we've engaged
in for many decades now and yet the
foreign policy never changes never
changes
no matter the Republicans get elected
the Democrats get elected we get more
immigration we get more Imperial Wars
abroad
we get more Outsourcing of our industry
we get a more of a reduction of of
religion in the Public Square
we get more weird sex stuff which again
I strongly suspect the majority of
Americans oppose and the polls reflect
that
what's that about
how how come
on on really important issues
the government no matter who's which
party is in power
never seems to pursue the will of the
people
because they're not accountable
because they don't have because the way
that the system is set up
they don't actually have to be
accountable it's true of the
corporations too
I mentioned this on the show yesterday
but we were told that you know listen
the government maybe that's really
corrupt but hey at least the
corporations are responding to Market
forces
you know Market incentives
well I don't I don't think that's the
case I think that the corporations are
responding to Blackrock and State Street
and Vanguard
pushing ESG policies among other
nefarious tactics to get those companies
to go woke and push weird sex stuff and
veganism and Hyper environmentalism and
all this kind of stuff that the majority
of the people don't want that's not
that's not company when Cracker Barrel I
keep using this example because it's so
absurd when Cracker Barrel
starts putting vegan sausage on the menu
which I promise you not one single
Cracker Barrel customer has ever asked
for then you know that it's not just
Market forces determining how these
companies work
you see it you see it when the big
corporations are silencing half the
country you know it's not just Market
forces determining that
speaking of the UK by the way uh it's
not all sunny news in in the UK there's
some sad news too uh the guy who who
just became the Prime Minister after Liz
truss resigned Liz truss was the
shortest serving prime minister in UK
history I just served just 45 days or so
a little bit more now that she's
officially out of office uh Rishi sunak
is the new prime minister he's the
former Chancellor of the exchequer he's
best known for signing all of those
covid checks on the big lockdown
policies from covid uh Rishi sunak is a
big fan and supporter of the world
economic Forum he also received even an
implicit endorsement of the Chinese
Communist party this guy is just
terrible I like him a little bit because
he looks somewhat like an Indian version
of me so I like having my you know
political cousins in office but the guy
and what's crazy is Rishi sunak is
supposedly a conservative he's
supposedly a tory
but he's not
Nigel farage came out he said he can't
support any candidate because as I said
as I said last week the globalist coup
has succeeded there is no conservative
party it is dead and in fact many in in
many ways the way that Rishi sunak
became the Prime Minister was because
the liberal establishment did not get
its preferred candidate when Liz trust
became prime minister and so they did
everything they could to tank the pound
and tank the British economy so that she
would be forced from office so that they
could get the much more liberal
candidate that they did want and why
because they want to undo brexit because
they want to undo Britain's new claims
for common sense and National
sovereignty and and they want to undo
all of that and so it's sort of like The
Empire Strikes Back
you seeing that here in the United
States too with our very favorite
Court Jester conservative that would be
of course Liz Cheney who is now
threatening uh if if Donald Trump is a
nominee in 2024 she's now threatening to
run for president herself
I'm focused on what we've got to do to
save the country from this very
dangerous moment we're in
um you know not right now on on whether
I'm going to be a candidate or not
there's some people suggest if you were
a third party candidate it would be
enough to stop Trump
well we will do whatever it takes as I
said he will not be the president United
States again
we will do whatever it takes he will not
be the president of the United States
now it sounds like Bluster
but
it is a little bit ominous actually
coming from Liz Cheney because even
though Liz Cheney pretends to be a
republican on all the crucial issues she
sides with the Democrats and she goes on
the Democrat TV stations and spouts
Democrat talking points and she is a a
representative of the Democrat
establishment which does have a lot of
power and which prevented Trump from
from winning re-election in 2020.
and admitted that they did that by
rigging the election in a very lengthy
Time magazine article
and and we know that they rigged the
election
we saw it especially in Pennsylvania we
saw a lot of Shenanigans in Georgia
Arizona
and elsewhere as well
so when when Liz Cheney comes out and
says Donald Trump will not be the
president
you do kind of Wonder you say okay look
Liz Cheney is never going to be
president sure
when this woman has no popular support
whatsoever
but
if she's speaking as a mouthpiece of the
liberal establishment as I think she is
then she might be onto something she
might say we we are going to do whatever
we can to stop the American people from
electing the person that they want
to save our sacred democracy we have to
stop the people from exercising their
Democratic rights and you're seeing the
same kind of talk well we talked about
at the very top of the show with that
MSNBC lady trying to knock down Doug
mastriano who is a gubernatorial
candidate in Pennsylvania we got the
election coming up very very soon we've
got Doug mastriano on the show actually
so you're going to want to stay tuned
because that is going to be on the
member block the rest of the show
continues now if you do not want to miss
it if you are not a member click the
link in the description and join us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]